hi this is Daniel Dwyer from GameSpot
reading the words of reviewer Austin
Walker project cars doesn't have
unlockables you don't amass a feat of
high-performance vehicles you don't buy
any new drive trains or earn prototype
engines you can choose to work your way
through a long career of tiered racing
events but even this is optional you can
just as easily start at the highest race
class with the best cars facing the
toughest competition rajae cars doesn't
deliver a fantasy of accumulation and
progress what it does deliver is a
simulation of racing as tense as it is
deep
this simulation is rolled out across
four modes the solo race and online
modes let you build any race you'd like
from the set of cars tracks motorsport
restrictions realism settings and
weather conditions available while the
range of vehicles is why there are some
notable absences if you're desperate to
drive Ferrari Porsche or Honda for
instance project cars isn't going to
meet that need but the cars that are
available look appropriately gorgeous on
learning each vehicles intricacies
offers a singular pleasure holding the
reins of a growling Ford Mustang is
widely different from zipping around the
truck and a little super cart
career mode puts you in the role of a
driver as you move from one tier to
another signing contracts with new teams
earning new sponsorship and going after
self-chosen goals and achievements a
range of Motorsports is available with
low tiers devoted to karts the middle
tier is offering some open wheel races
and GT events and the top tier is
introducing prototype racing series and
the final mode is driver network which
offers players the chance to compete
against each other in an asynchronous
time trial challenge winning means not
just racing well but by understanding
how to tune your car to better fit the
races tracking conditions there are
dozens of characteristics for you to
learn about adjust and test out change
how open your radiator is modify your
gear timing increase or reduce tire
pressure and even manage your fuel load
each of these has some sort of effect on
your driving and if you really hope to
compete
you can't take a one-size-fits-all
approach you'll need to learn what all
of these options mean unfortunately
unless you already know the ins and outs
of car tuning this means that you'll
need to seek help outside of the game
the bottom of the tuning screen says you
can troubleshoot issues by asking your
engineer but there's not actually a way
to do that in the game short
descriptions of the tuning options give
you a broad idea but further specifics
you'll need to turn to fan-made guides
and tutorial videos this is a problem
for project cars because it makes
approaching the game on its own terms
much harder it doesn't help that the AI
racers in career and solo modes are so
inconsistent with the default difficulty
settings the other drivers vary between
smartly aggressive and totally passive
why should you spend an hour learning
how to master the line of sonoma raceway
if you can win by a margin of 12 seconds
even when you don't put time into
studying the track couple this with a
rare but very annoying bug that randomly
switches you from first to last place
and the whole experience can get a
little bit sour
the multiplayer mode sidestepped the
problem of unpredictable AI and it's in
the online competition the project cars
shines brightest online it all comes
together it's the last lap and you're
fighting for space against a group of
ten other real-life players you pull
ahead and suddenly you're neck and neck
for first place going into the final
straightaway you notice it before your
rival does his car just isn't keeping up
with juries after the race is over and
everyone is congratulating everyone else
on a good race your rival says something
like man I don't know what happened
there it's like the car just gave out on
me and though you can't be sure you
think you know that it's because of how
much fuel was left in the tank you
tested that during the practice session
and that work had paid off
that's project cars at its best no
experience points no parts to buy no
cars to add to your collection the
audacious decision to offer everything
upfront it forms the rest of project
cars design making it distinct and
sometimes frustrating other games in the
genre work like Skinner boxes offering
rewards according to a special schedule
designed to keep the player hooked these
games offer a fantasy of plotting
constant accumulation or low stakes
action project cars offers a different
fantasy one that's a little less
attractive and a bit harder to enjoy the
fantasy of learning had to do something
difficult
you